you learn about different guys how they  fit around Kevin and Kyrie  somebody was just on the court  [Applause]  just  flew out of the stands onto the court  and now everybody's standing up in that  area  and they're gonna have to clean it up  a little spillage all right this is next  level spillage it's not even  entertaining spillage  [Applause]  unnecessary and stupid  and a waste of time  Durant getting ready and stuff from up  high yep  yeah that's dangerous you have no idea  what's coming out of the stands  [Music]  yep  landed though everything was funny  sprawled out out of the cup onto the  floor  so they'll go to work dry it off  he's got a stoppage at the 140 Mark of  OT  with Dallas up 125 to 117.